[Music]
good morning Hank it's Monday July knife
welcome to my desk bedroom by the way
for the last two weeks have been giving
you a tour of my house have you noticed
Hank over the last few days several
commenters and also some people in my
pants have said that you and I
textually communicated on purpose
because we missed getting punished would
that it were so the fact of the matter
is that we're just really stupid I mean
I don't think you're that stupid I think
that you are probably doing six things
at once and just happen to textually
communicate with me I think that I'm
stupid I don't enjoy punishments
although I do enjoy you getting punished
Hank to prove to you that I didn't get
punished on purpose I'm going to
recreate the actual textual
communication that we had so I'm sitting
around working on a new book think about
what the title should be and all of a
sudden on my screen up pops and video
chat requests from you and I say to
myself well you know video is it text so
that's allowed so I hit okay but for
some reason it doesn't work doesn't go
through and then I get a text screen
pops up and it says okay I'm here now
and I'm like is that Kathryn did Kathryn
log on to Hanks I am
and so I say Kathryn and the person
responds no Hank and then I'm like
yes yes yes and I'm sitting there and
I'm thinking to myself he's gonna get
punished
he's so punished and then I just wanted
to tell you Hank I just wanted to tell
you how punished you were and so I said
dude you are so punished then I hit
return wait I just need to take a quick
timeout from this story just to say
nerdfighters honestly Hank
even after I typed enter even after I
saw the words dude you are so punished
pop up on the screen I was just like
don't be do did you have a dad I do do
and then I notice that you weren't
writing back and I was like why is it
Hank writing back to me and then I said
oh right it's because we're not texting
you communicating dull stupid stupid
stupid oh good Dornish I think that we
have your punishment all set up in my
pants
it looks like your punishment is
definitely going to involve wait can we
can we go ahead and can we cue up the
yes yes it's going to involve recreating
that I don't know the other details but
it's definitely going to involve
recreating that picture as for my
punishment it doesn't seem like anyone
settled on anything and Hank maybe you
could go into my pants and help people
talk about it and pick stuff that you
think would be particularly harmful to
me oh and Hank quick sidenote I know
that we can't veto our punishments
obviously because then they wouldn't be
punishments but I do think that our
wives should have the right to veto
punishments that the nerdfighters
suggest for us because nothing against
the nerdfighters but sometimes they
suggest punishments that are sort of
maniacal like oh I think you should have
to do your happy dance in public two
hundred times and then after that you
should have to saw off your leg now the
fact that I don't want to saw my leg
shouldn't figure into the punishment
thing at all but the fact that the Yeti
doesn't want me to solve my leg that's a
deal breaker to me so I hope we can
agree wives have veto power and I will
see you tomorrow but more importantly
hopefully by Thursday I will see this
guy again